It's happening again. In his farewell
address, President Eisenhower warned us
of the rise of the military-industrial
complex. In Biden's farewell address, he
warned us of the tech industrial
complex. And something super weird
happened recently. Poll after poll shows
the vast majority of Americans agree AI
needs regulation. I mean, currently AI
companies are regulated less than a taco
cart, which is just insane. And yet,
despite this, bizarrely, big tech almost
successfully lobbyed Congress to ban
states from regulating AI entirely for
10 years. 10 years. So, what on earth
happened? How did they almost pull off
something so wildly unpopular? Well, the
answer may surprise you. First of all,
they're spending a fortune in dark money
lobbying, but that's obvious. The AI
industry has more lobbyists in
Washington and Brussels than the fossil
fuel industry and the tobacco industry
combined. Zuckerberg alone is
outspending all of civil society 10 to1.
And what narrative are they pushing with
all that money? Fear of China, an AI
arms race. But why? Well, it's an old
trick to manipulate public opinion. Fear
cells. Throughout the Cold War, the
military-industrial complex spent a
fortune pushing the false narrative that
the Soviets were far more advanced than
they actually were, which ensured the
money from Congress kept flowing. It was
called the missile and the bomber gap.
They lied and lied and lied again to get
bigger and bigger defense contracts.
Now, obviously, there is some amount of
competition between the US and China,
but big tech is lying and exaggerating
like crazy to terrify Congress into
giving them whatever they want. And what
they want is fat government contracts
and zero democratic oversight. Now, it
seems like not a day goes by without
another big AI company announcing a
giant contract with the Department of
Defense. But, are we actually in a race?
Let's go back in time. In January 2025,
China challenged years of American AI
dominance with the release of DeepSeek
R1, wiping more than a trillion dollars
off the American stock market.
Billionaire Mark Andre was everywhere,
claiming that China was now ahead of the
US in AI. Well, are they? According to
the AI researchers behind AI 2027, there
are three main pillars that would decide
a US China AI arms race.
China, previously thought to be years
behind, had potentially closed the gap
to mere months. So, if China supposedly
had their foot on the accelerator, why
wouldn't they completely catch up or
even surpass the US? China has amazing
AI talent, a big infrastructure
advantage, and top-notch companies. The
answer is that the country that holds
the real power over who wins the AI race
isn't China or the US.
It's Taiwan. The most valuable company
in the world right now isn't Microsoft,
Google or Apple. It's Nvidia because
they are supplying the GPUs or AI chips
fueling the entire AI race. According to
the researchers, the whole AI race comes
down to one thing, computing power, also
known as compute. AI companies are
spending as much as they possibly can on
computing power. Hundreds of billions of
dollars. Because the bottleneck to
scaling increasingly smarter AI systems
isn't money. It's cuttingedge chips.
But here's the catch. Nvidia doesn't
actually manufacture those chips. That
job falls to Taiwan Semiconductor
Manufacturing Company or TSMC. They've
been working together since 1998, which
shows just how long the two companies
have relied on each other. TSMC depends
on equipment produced by America and its
allies, putting it within the US sphere
of influence. Taiwan and China have been
geopolitical adversaries ever since the
Chinese civil war between the PRC and
the ROC ended in 1949 with the ROC
retreating from mainland China to the
island of Taiwan. So since 2022, the US
has banned companies like Nvidia from
selling top tier chips to China. This
left China with almost no good options
to obtain the best chips. Crazily enough
roughly 20% of all of China's chips come
in from smuggling. You could get paid $1
million per suitcase of GPUs you bring
to the country. But the rabbit hole
keeps going. The same band has also
torpedoed China's own chipmaking
industry. Before 2022, all the best
Chinese-made chips were made using
special silicon chips called wafers made
by TSMC. Without access to those,
Chinese chip makers have scrambled to
come up with replacements. China's best
domestic chip manufacturer, SMIC, lags a
few years behind TSMC. This leads to a
massive difference. The researchers
estimated that the United States had 75%
of the world's supply of the advanced
chips needed for AI development with
China having 15% and the rest of the
world combined having 10%. Google alone
has probably 15% of all the world's
compute while DeepS has maybe 1%. This
is a huge deal. The US has five times
the compute as China. So claims that
America is losing the AI arms race feels
strikingly similar to what US military
contractors were saying about the Soviet
Union during the Cold War to get larger
defense contracts. In fact, while tech
billionaires like Mark Andre claimed
that Deepseek was a Sputnik moment,
showing that China was actually ahead of
the US, Deepseek's own CEO accidentally
revealed last year just how much the
chip ban had hurt them. mid last year,
the CEO of Deep Seek, they were working
in in total obscurity. And what he says
is he's like, "Yeah, so honestly, like
we're really excited and doing this AGI
push or whatever." And like honestly,
like money's not the problem for us.
Talent's not the problem for us, but
like access to compute, like these
export controls, man, that's a real
problem for us. Oh boy.
>> Nothing can stop us on the path to AGI
except access to compute. He who
controls the chips controls the future
of AI. So when it comes to the first
pillar of AI development, compute, the
US is winning by far. But there are two
more major potential bottlenecks that
could actually tell us if we're in an AI
arms race. Because it doesn't just take
advanced chips to train smarter AI
models. You also need energy. China has
surpassed the US in energy, but that
power means nothing if China doesn't
have the AI chips they need. And the US
has enough potential energy sources that
it could unlock that energy won't become
a bottleneck for AI. Besides the new
solar installations and revived nuclear
reactors, for the last decade, US gas
power plants have only been running at
around half of their total capacity,
meaning that the US can grow energy
production even without building new
plants. Energy, while critical, won't be
the bottleneck that slows the US down
enough for China to catch up. Okay, so
what about people? China has four times
as many people as the US and twice as
many STEM PhDs. But the US gets to draw
in the sharpest minds from the rest of
the world. Take OpenAI founder Ilia
Sutsk who was born in Russia or Google
DeepMind founder Demis who was born in
London. The talent battle isn't USA
versus China. It's China versus the rest
of the world. But even if China had more
talent, it wouldn't matter because the
specific goals of AI companies is to
create an intelligence explosion
scenario by having AIs themselves do AI
research. This would increase the total
amount of talent on both sides by 10 or
100 times. NVIDIA's CEO thinks that the
company will have 100 million AI workers
in the next few years. AIS will recruit
other AIs to solve problems. AIS will be
in, you know, Slack channels with each
other. As AI workers increasingly
contribute to research and to
algorithmic advances, talent ceases to
become a bottleneck. The only remaining
bottleneck is compute. And there the US
is already crushing China with the US
having five times as much compute. And
the US would pull even further ahead
after closing the few remaining
loopholes that China has been using to
circumvent the chip ban. So if the US
already controls the chips, the talent,
and has the energy it needs, why the
panic? Why are senators pounding the
table, warning that we can't afford to
lose the AI race? It's simple. Big tech
is pouring millions into lobbying
Congress to spread the narrative that
China is sprinting ahead and that even
the tiniest amount of regulation would
hand China the race. But in reality,
China's AI industry is the most
regulated in the entire world. In fact,
even a Xi Jinping himself says he
doesn't want an AI arms race, saying
that China should abandon unhited growth
that comes at the cost of sacrificing
safety. Let that sink in. So, if the
idea of an AI race is so unpopular, both
in the Chinese leadership and among the
American public, who are the people
arguing that we need a race to beat
China? Andre Horowitz or A16Z is a
venture capital firm with 42 billion in
assets and is deeply invested in AI.
Shockingly, they don't want regulation
on AI. And what better way to sell
American lawmakers on the need to go
fast than convincing everyone that the
US is in a new global arms race. Andre
Horowitz is a backer of the American
Innovators Network, which has plans to
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
on opposing a New York State AI safety
bill. The opposition is spreading
outright lies like the bill would kill
all of New York's AI startups when in
reality, the regulation would only apply
to big tech companies spending over
hund00 million on training frontier
models. This is the classic playbook.
But who else is trying to sell US
lawmakers on the idea of an AI brace?
The tech company CEOs themselves. The
biggest fear-mongerer in the space is
Zuckerberg. The playbook is simple. Big
Tobacco used it to cast doubt that
smoking was actually bad for you. Big
oil uses the same playbook to cast doubt
on climate change. There's a fantastic
book on the topic called Virgins of
Doubt that I highly recommend except in
AI it's more like they are merchants of
fear.
For example, Zuckerberg has pumped at
least $40 million that we know of into a
front group called American Edge.
American Edge spent millions of dollars
blasting out Facebook ads to millions of
people, declaring that banning states
from regulating AI will protect American
innovation and jobs. But these AI
companies explicit goal is to use AI to
replace all human labor, which yeah,
might have an effect on jobs. Yeah,
okay. Big shocker that this is what
Zuckerberg is up to, but it's not just
him.
>> We must continue to run faster. Uh, this
is a race.
>> That woman is Lisa Sue, AMD CEO,
Nvidia's biggest competitor at selling
AI chips. Right next to her is OpenAI
CEO Sam Alman, who wants Congress to
ensure that AI has very loose and
permissive regulations. Sam Alman claims
to support regulating AI because of how
dangerous future models might be. But
unsurprisingly, like most industry
monopolists, whenever journalists or
senators ask him what specific
regulation he would like, he dodges the
question and an extremely light touch AI
safety bill was passed in both chambers
in California with an overwhelming
majority of support from civil society.
But vetoed by Governor Gavin Newsome,
big AI companies heavily lobbied against
the bill. And who does Nuome have deep
donor ties to? You guessed it. And the
stakes here aren't just escalation
toward World War II, but potentially
much worse. These companies and VCs have
the explicit goal of creating artificial
super intelligence, an AI system that
could outperform humans at everything.
But according to the Godfathers of AI
and the company's CEOs themselves, if we
create this super intelligence as
quickly as possible without spending the
time to make sure it's safe, the results
could be literal human extinction. And
the bad case, and I think this is like
important to say, is like lights out for
all of us. And the risk of this is
frighteningly high. Jeffrey Hinton,
who's a Nobel laureate, thinks that the
odds of humanity going extinct is a coin
flip.
We have to face the possibility
that unless we do something
soon,
we're near the end.
Even the CEO of Google himself said that
the odds of extinction from AI are
actually pretty high. Sit with that for
a moment. He told Lex Friedman he's an
optimist because he thinks humanity will
rally to prevent catastrophe. In other
words, that humanity will rally to stop
him from building the thing he is
building. This timeline is wild. Okay,
but there may be a solution to all this
madness. The head of DeepMind believes
that this is a problem that nations
can't solve by competing. but by
cooperating. In the same way that we
have CERN, he believes that we need a
CERN for AGI. Right now, the US is by
far the leader in AI and could use that
leverage over China to negotiate a
bilateral treaty regulating AI
development. And instead of creating
fake AI arms races, humanity could
actually work together.
Hey, I'm Drew. If you want to see a
concrete, deeply researched scenario of
how actually AI could take over written
by AI researchers, watch this video
next. Thanks for watching. This video
took a long time to make and I
appreciate all your